so I'm a computer scientist I man also
an interaction designer what I want to
talk to you two about today is how to
leverage interaction not just to make
systems more usable from a healthcare
perspective but actually how to leverage
interaction data to put as a source of
data for healthcare but before I get
there let me talk about what something
that you all up really understand
already which is we're in the midst of
an amazing technological revolution
right you can see vast amounts of
sensors we're in the top left DC sensors
that were really only accessible to
researchers and scientists how they
progress to the sensors on the right
hand side which are you know my children
can use because they're based out of
Lego parts all the way down to what we
can buy today for a hundred dollars a
pop consumer level technology that's
really usable and really quite effective
in collecting basic data about our
everyday behaviors similarly we've seen
a big change in what's available from
the mobile side right if we no longer
have these mobile phones our car phones
that you know are this big and you had
to have a briefcase to carry them and we
see things that are much smaller one of
the really nice advantages of having the
sort of plethora of mobile devices is
that the devices not only provide us
information a trickle story that these
devices not only provided us a really
nice way to collect data about
individuals as they go throughout their
everyday life but they provide really
nice tools to poor visualizing that data
for providing feedback about that data
now I was at an NSF NIH meeting last
week in Washington DC and someone from
the National Science Foundation said
there were approximately 15,000 health
related applications on the Apple App
Store one of the issues I have with many
of these applications that are out there
is that they really are very good at
provide collecting data mostly
self-reported data and presenting you
that raw data but what they don't do
is to help you convert that data to
useful information so this is one of my
favorite graphics where it really I
think illustrates the point of how the
challenges that need to be overcome in
order to convert data to information to
knowledge so that you can take action on
it and I think that's where the users of
the technologies that we produce really
have a struggle with and I think we've
heard a lot about that over the past day
and a half one of the issues that we
have to face our how to connect to
convert data to information is how to
value context so contextual information
is really important for understanding
the data that's being collected we have
to support users and being able to
create questions about their data
scaffold them in being able to form
hypotheses and prove and disprove these
hypotheses and that's one of the things
my group at Carnegie Mellon is focusing
on where we're looking at how to collect
large amounts of data about individuals
mostly about the routines and their you
about their human behaviors their
routines and behaviors and leverage that
data to improve their health care
situation so in moving from what we want
is a healthy individual to the topic of
my talk which is a healthy home I think
there's a number of things we need to
start looking at the first is how can we
leverage everyday activities right so
the everyday activities you see in this
slide are taking medicine doing the
laundry reading the newspaper reading a
book filling a balancing your checkbook
these are all instruments instrumental
activities of daily living sort of core
activities that someone put would
perform in their home and I think these
kinds of activities really stand apart
from a lot of the technologies we've
seen previously in this conference so
there's been a lot of focus on a device
that I'll go and buy from the store like
a Fitbit or a zero or something like
that and use it and wear it very
explicitly similarly we've seen
technology that you would find in the
clinicians office that when you go into
your see your clinician the clinician
would pull it out put it on you collect
some data from you and then you move on
the kind of data I'm really interested
in is the kind of data that you can
collect when people are just performing
their everyday activities so I want to
introduce
do to dwell sense dwell sense is the
product of several years worth of work
it was the culmination of my PhD student
Matthew Lee's PhD thesis Matthew is now
left CMU he's a researcher at Phillips
research and this is work that was
sponsored by the Robert Wood Johnson
Foundation pioneer a pioneer portfolio
as well as the National Science
Foundation dwell sense is the technology
that I'm talking about it's an example
of the technology i'm talking about
could go back one slide please google
back one slide please thank you so this
technology thing trigger heavier this
technology is really looking at how can
we collect information about everyday
behavior by instrumenting the artifacts
that people interact with in an everyday
behavior so we have things like a
pillbox right this is basically a five
dollar pillbox 7 day 7 days pillbox that
you can buy from rite aid what's
actually two they're just super glued
back to back so on one side as you can
see in the image there's batteries and
their sensors and there's there's
hardware all in here but on the other
side it's basically a regular pillbox
right and so what kind of information
can we collect for this we're really
interesting collecting to two kinds of
information that are to data with two
particular characteristics this data set
up is really meant to help us understand
and push and assess cognitive decline in
elders in seniors so how can we
instrument their everyday activities
instrument the artifacts they use on an
everyday basis to be able to collect
information about cognitive decline the
second thing that we're really
interested in is how to do it in a way
that doesn't affect how they perform
those activities so we took three of
those instrumental activities of daily
living ones that we thought we could
sense relatively easily and ones that
were that where they provided some
concrete value to our subjects to our
users and so the key thing behind the
technology because there's plenty of
pill boxes out there that will tell you
whether someone's been successful at
taking their medicine there's the pill
pill bottles there's other things that
look like this that collect information
about whether you're successful and we
care a little bit less about whether you
were successful or not then about the
quality of your performance
so one of the things you notice when if
you have an if you have an elder elderly
parent or a loved one that's undergoing
cognitive decline is that the decline
the changes in the performance actually
occurs much earlier than you see them
making mistakes right someone can be
perfectly successful at taking their
medicine but the quality of the
performance of taking that medicine may
it be exhibited long before they start
having problems so let me give you a
concrete example so you may have a
parent that is having difficulty
remembering what day of the week it is
right so their sensors on here that can
basically tell you okay the open sunday
the open Monday and now they've open
Tuesday which is today right so they got
it they got it right they were
successfully taking their medicine but
what the system is able to capture is
how well the performance of that
activity was so there's lots of sensors
in here there's things to list know when
the door has been open there's
accelerometers in here to let you know
when it's been turned over if there's
sensors in here to help to let us know
when they're having physically dipped
physical difficulty as I am right now in
opening this box similarly we
instrumented similarly we instrumented
telephone which it'll catch up this soon
I hope we move to the next slide all
right I'll just keep talking so we
instrumented a telephone to let us know
when people are making phone calls and
particularly we're interested in the
quality of misdial okay now would have
jumped ahead and then we've instrumented
a coffee maker so a coffee maker is a
really good example of a multi-step
process making coffee as an example of a
multi-step process where you can do some
of the steps in not quite the right
order and still get a cup of coffee we
want to know you know did the people put
it did their users do they put the
coffee filter in so we have sensors to
know when they got water when they put
the carafe into the coffee maker when
they put water into the reservoir so we
can sense all of these different steps
of the process to understand what the
performance is with these activities of
daily living the architecture is
basically this we have the sensors
instrumented in these artifacts
instrumented throughout someone's
environment we wirelessly set
transmitted all to a laptop and then
from the
laptop we use the internet and an
Internet access to be able to do some
cloud-based analytics which allow us to
do things like produce web-based graft
primarily and a real-time feedback
display so we instrumented this in 14 so
I go back one slide please we
instrumented this in 14 homes of seniors
and you can see these are pretty messy
environment these are not clean
environment these are not laboratory
studies some of our subjects would spill
their nail polish over they eat over
these devices and you can see
highlighted the laptop behind the TV and
the pill box in the living room so these
were pretty messy environments and we
were lucky that when the technology
lasted two weeks at a time so we were
kind of replacing these we deliberately
under engineered the system so that we
could get reliable data but we were paid
the cost of going on replacing batteries
in placing the system so we put this
into 14 of seniors homes and then we
provided a display on a tablet just like
this in turn this on and basically the
tablet gives them a real-time feedback
about what the system is doing what the
system is collecting about them so on
the top left you can see that the person
that there's a green circle around the
am medicine so this was tracking morning
medicine and afternoon medicine for this
or evening medicine for this individual
and you can see they took the medicine
on time at six-twenty you can see that
the Sunday and Monday tabs of the pill
box are LED and yellow which means they
open the sunday and monday and then they
correctly opened the green Tuesday in
the they did not take their evening
medicine and from that we use a bunch of
heuristics a series of heuristics that
we developed over time to give them
scores on the correctness of the
activity as well as the timeliness of
this activity so you can see those in
the bars to the right similarly we have
this kind of data for making phone calls
as well as for the coffee making task
and for the coffee making task we break
it up into a series of steps that
correspond to the sensors that we have
in our system one of the things that's
really allowed us to do was the display
helped reorient our users to better
understand how well they were performing
these activities
before did you think you were doing it
regularly yeah absolutely I would have
bet my life that I did I didn't miss any
days because that's one of this
old you actually physically said no that
couldn't be I know I took it today
needed I hate to know that I hate to
acknowledge that because it's just
another thing to get him like Avenue
it's sure to get show you what you're
doing wrong so our subject had the
ability by reflecting on this data on an
everyday basis to really see how well
they're performing these activities not
just whether they were successful or not
but actually how well they were
performing these activities so one of
the things we can see here in this graph
is that we just looking at medication
adherence just looking at the display
actually improved medication adherence
so this is a really crude graph where
green dots so that you got a time line
across the bottom these are two
different subjects on the green dots
mean that they took the pill on time
yellow meant that they tipped their pill
late and red means they forgot that pill
so before we introduce the display you
can see there's a fair amount of noise
in terms of when how successful they
were at this task but then after we
introduced the display there's this
really nice regularity that happens
particularly for the top subjects but
even for the bottom subject you can see
that for at least october november they
didn't miss any medicine medication and
they did weren't late on any other
medication as well so without this would
be this tablet device acting as a
reminder system with it actually acting
as a way to allow users to reflect on
the performance of their behavior they
actually improve the performance of
their behavior which was a real trust
was a really nice finding a second thing
that we saw was in terms of real time
versus long-term displays so half about
the elders in our study we gave them the
real-time display in the other half we
gave them we didn't show them any data
we collected data for four months we
said okay after four months look at this
data and tell us what you think and it
was really quite interesting what we
found it really served to shock them
into reality so they thought that they
were performing well as you heard in the
quote before but then after seeing four
months of data they realized just how
poorly they were performing on some of
these activities like making coffee
taking medicine and making miss Stiles
with their phone the good thing is that
that shock had a really nice impact of
act improving their behavior the
negative thing is it only tended to last
on average three to four weeks so the
long-term the display was really
effective but the effect of it was quite
short-lived unfortunately so what I've
talked about so far is how this kind of
technology helps with helps reorient
individuals so they're more aware of
their behavior as well as how it helps
them perform better in these behaviors
the thing I think that's most appealing
to me about this technology that we've
been developing that others are
similarly developing is that it can be
used as an early assessment of a
cognitive decline and so here we were
looking at we brought in occupational
therapists to come in and do regular
assessments similar to the task that we
had people perform now an occupational
therapist might see somebody once every
six months and have them perform some
fairly artificial tasks so the nice
thing about the technology is what you
see on the screen it's automated its
objective it's cheap it's frequently
repeated it's continuous assessment and
not only do we want it to provide
assistance to occupational therapists we
also think this data would be relatively
useful for clinicians so look at this
diagram or this graph for one individual
subject 14 in our study this person was
doing pretty well through august through
november but then in january the patient
had a bad fall was hospitalized and do
the complications passed away pretty
quickly now one of the things we would
notice when in retrospect when we look
back at the data is that in november and
december just looking at the medication
insurance perspective there's a lot of
missing pills now i'm not we're not
saying that a clinician would have
noticed this or let the clinician would
even asked for this data but the data
was there and i think this just goes to
illustrate how valuable this kind of
data can be in the clinical care
practice so the wealth sense can support
greater awareness of tasks it can
improve this medication adherence which
is obviously a really important problem
it can help find these earlier in early
indicators of cognitive decline and
adverse offense events and similarly a
complied assistance to occupational
therapists and our goal is to so is
hopefully to provide value in the
physician's office which is something we
have to show next thank you very much
you